let's go to our next caller from the 262
area code who's calling today from - six
- hi Vikki Herman yes again I'm one of
your right-wing Sam and I'm wondering if
you have any idea of when all this
low-hanging fruit they're generation is
into one will finally take that like
rank choice voting military in half term
limits this sort of thing I don't have
an answer unfortunately I mean III would
I would like to see many of those ideas
implemented soon I agree that they are
low-hanging fruit in the sense that
these are pretty obvious things that we
should be doing it's not low-hanging
fruit in the sense that it's easy to
accomplish politically there would be
big opposition so I don't know in what
sense if you mean low-hanging fruit as
like hey we should obviously do these
things I'm with you if you mean
low-hanging fruit in it should have been
easy to do them already I don't know
about that well I mean yeah I have
plenty of left-wing and right-wing fans
and they they're not Sam's friends and
they all seem to agree on this list but
you know I'm yeah why doesn't it happen
well a lot of those things challenge the
institutions of power so term limits
everybody who got in got in without term
limits they're not particularly
incentivized to put in place term limits
that might get them out of office a lot
of the people that got in got in
supporting the military-industrial
complex being funded by defense
contractors etc so they're not really
the people who are going to go in and
cut the size of the military in half so
you have to understand that that there's
a there's unaligned incentives there
well hopefully if we can change those
incentives can I ask one other quick
question sure huh yeah um I've some
money left for me in a vanguard
healthcare account and I'm wondering
what will happen to that sort of account
is some sort of Medicare for all is that
my sense is that any accounts that are
for sort of like pre designated health
care spending so I think this would
include like HSAs and so on and so forth
I assume that if Medicare for all takes
all of that money will be sort of
allowed to be moved out of those
sequestered funds that have to be there
it's a health care mutual fund it's a
health care mutual fund so we just
invest in health care compounds sorry
yeah
you're gonna want to get out of that I
think if Medicare for all passes yeah
yeah yeah
good to know all right very good thank
you so much for the call I appreciate it
let's take a quick break if you're
holding don't hang up because we will go
right back to the phones right after
this short break